PLACE AT THAT MOMENT AND THEN
HELD THE DECISIVE 15th VOTE FOR
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE.
JOINING US NOW TO TALK ABOUT
THIS.
WHAT A NIGHT IT WAS, CNN SENIOR
POLITICAL ANALYST RON
BROWNSTEIN.
RON, GAETZ SAYS BECAUSE OF ALL
OF THE CONCESSIONS HE MADE
McCARTHY WILL ESSENTIALLY GOVERN
AS SPEAKER IN A STRAIGHT JACKET.
GAETZ IS GIVEN TO HYPERBOLE, AND
I'M BEING GENEROUS, BUT HE IS
NOT ALL TOGETHER OFF, IS HE?
>> NO.
WHO, BY THE WAY, KNEW WE WOULD
HAVE FRIDAY NIGHT FIGHTS,
CAPITOL HILL EDITION?
>> RIGHT.
>> LOOK, I THINK WHAT COMES OUT
OF THIS IS WE ARE GOING TO TEST
A LONG, LONG HELD ARGUMENT OF
CONSERVATIVES, LITERALLY FOR AS
LONG AS YOU AND I HAVE BEEN
COVERING POLITICS THERE HAVE
BEEN CONSERVATIVES WHO ARGUED
THAT IF REPUBLICANS GAVE VOTERS
KIND OF THE FULL, UNDILUTED TRUE
STUFF THAT THEY WOULD WIN MORE
ELECTIONS.
NOW AFTER A MIDTERM IN WHICH
REPUBLICANS WERE CLEARLY HURT IN
SWING DISTRICTS AND SWING STATES
BY THE VIEW, PARTICULARLY AMONG
INDEPENDENTS THAT THEY WERE
EXTREMISTS, THE RIGHT HAS
ACHIEVED THE POWER IN THE HOUSE
TO BASICALLY TEST THAT
PROPOSITION.
I MEAN KEVIN McCARTHY DID WHAT
JOHN BOEHNER AND PAUL RYANN
WOULD NOT DO.
HE WAS WILLING TO MAKE
CONCESSIONS THAT THEY WOULD NOT
MAKE.
THE RESULT WILL BE ENORMOUS
INFLUENCE AND VISIBILITY FOR THE
MOST MILITANT MEMBERS OF THE
CAUCUS AND DEFINING REPUBLICANS
OVER THE NEXT TWO YEARS, AND
WHATEVER THAT MEANS FOR THE
REPUBLICANS IN MORE CENTRIST AND
SWING DISTRICTS WE WILL HAVE TO
SEE.
>> RON, WE HAVE BEEN FOCUSED,
ALL OF US, ON THE INFIGHTING IN
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY OVER THE
LAST WEEK, BUT IT HAS REAL-WORLD
IMPLICATIONS FOR EVERYBODY.
COULD WE HAVE A SCENARIO, RON,
THAT EMERGES AS THE DEBT CEILING
VOTE APPROACHES WHERE A HANDFUL
OF HARD-RIGHT LAWMAKERS HAVE THE
ABILITY TO GRIND EVERYTHING TO A
HALT AND POTENTIALLY PUT THE
NATION INTO DEFAULT?
>> THE ANSWER IS YES.
>> LEADING TO THINGS LIKE, YOU
KNOW, STOCK MARKET PLUMMETING
AND SO ON?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I MEAN, LOOK, WHAT YOU'VE GOT IS
A SITUATION WHERE ACROSS THE
BOARD McCARTHY HAS GIVEN THE
MOST MILITANT CONSERVATIVE
MEMBERS OF THE CAUCUS MORE
LEVERAGE THAN THEY'VE EVER HAD
TO SHAPE THE AGENDA.
I MEAN CLEARLY, YOU KNOW, HE
SPECIFICALLY CONCEDED ON THE
DEBT CEILING, NOT TO HAVE A
CLEAN UP-OR-DOWN VOTE BUT TO
RAISE CONCESSIONS.
THAT BY DEFINITION WILL NOT BE
ACCEPTABLE TO SENATE DEMOCRATS
AND PRESIDENT BIDEN, THE IDEA OF
TYING THE DEBT CEILING TO
CUTTING SOCIAL SECURITY OR
MEDICARE OR DISCRETIONARY
SPENDING.
>> RIGHT.
AND THERE ARE EVEN SOME, I
SUPPOSE, REPUBLICANS WHO WON'T
WANT TO GO ALONG WITH THAT SORT
OF THING.
>> YEAH.
>> AND WE KNOW POLITICS IS MESSY
SOMETIMES, LET'S NOT SUGAR COAT
HOW NASTY THINGS GOT AS WE WERE
JUST TALKING AND REPLAYING THAT
INTERVIEW I HAD WITH CONGRESSMAN
BURCHETT THIS AFTERNOON.
AT ONE POINT CONGRESSMAN ROGERS
OF ALABAMA HAD TO BE RESTRAINED
AFTER HE MADE A MOVE TOWARDS
MATT GAETZ.
LOOKED LIKE HE WAS LUNGING AT
HIM OR WAS GOING TO STICK A
FINGER IN HIS FACE, WE'RE NOT
REALLY SURE.
I KNOW TEMPERS ARE BOUND TO GET
SHORT.
YOU HAVE WATCHED THIS KIND OF
STUFF PLAY OUT FOR YEARS, RON.
DID THAT SURPRISE YOU?
>> YES.
SHORT ANSWER, YES.
I MEAN THIS IS WHAT YOU READ
ABOUT MORE IN THE 19th CENTURY
WHEN PHYSICAL ALTERCATIONS ON
THE FLOOR OF THE HOUSE, MOST
FAMOUSLY THE CANING DURING THE
CIVIL WAR WERE MORE COMMON.
BUT TO ME THERE WERE DEFINING
IMAGES LAST NIGHT AND THEY
REPRESENT THE TWO RISKS THAT
McCARTHY TOOK TO GET THE JOB.
ONE IS THE IMAGE OF ROGERS
LUNGING AT GAETZ.
THAT'S A QUESTION OF COMING
ACROSS AS DYSFUNCTIONAL, NOT
READY FOR PRIMETIME, NOT REALLY
CAPABLE OF RUNNING THE
INSTITUTION.
I THINK AN EVEN BIGGER RISK IS
THE SECOND DEFINING IMAGE OF THE
NIGHT WHICH IS WHEN MARJORIE
TAYLOR GREENE WHO WAS EXCLUDED
FROM COMMITTEES WHILE DEMOCRATS
RAN THE PLACE ON -- CITING HER
PREVIOUS REMARKS ABOUT VIOLENCE
AND CONSPIRACY THEORIES AND
ANTI-ISLAMIC AND SO FORTH
COMMENTS, SHE RACED DOWN THE
AISLE TO TAKE A PHOTO, A SELFIE
WITH KEVIN McCARTHY, WHICH MAY
HAVE BEEN HIS FIRST ACT AS
SPEAKER.
YOU KNOW, ADAM KINZINGER --
>> AND, RON, REMEMBER, SHE HELD
UP HER PHONE TO MATT ROSENDALE
OF MONTANA, AND ON THE PHONE THE
PHOTOGRAPHERS, THE GREAT
PHOTOGRAPHERS WE HAVE HERE IN
WASHINGTON, CAPTURED THAT IMAGE.
IT SAID, "DT," THERE IT IS, ON
THE PHONE.
SHE IS TRYING TO SEND A MESSAGE
TO THE HOLDOUTS THAT TRUMP IS ON
THE LINE.
>> BUT THE FACT THAT WHEN IT
FINALLY BROKE FROM FOR McCARTHY
SHE WAS LITERALLY THE FIRST ONE
WITH HIM, TAKING THIS PHOTO,
IMMEDIATELY POSTING ON SOCIAL
MEDIA, IS AN INDICATION OF WHAT
THE NEXT TWO YEARS ARE GOING TO
BE LIKE.
THESE FOLKS ARE GOING TO BE
INCREASINGLY THE FACE OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY, PEOPLE LIKE
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE, MATT
GAETZ.
THEY WILL BE AT THE CENTER OF
THE IMAGERY IN MANY OF THESE
INVESTIGATIONS THAT McCARTHY
AGREED TO, INCLUDING ONE ON THE
WEAPONIZATION -- EXACT WORD --
OF THE FBI AND JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
GREENE SAYS SHE WANTS TO
INVESTIGATE WHETHER THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS BEING UNFAIR TO
THE JANUARY 6th
INSURRECTIONISTS, AND NOW -- I
MEAN IT IS GOING TO GREATLY
FACILITATE THE ABILITY OF
DEMOCRATS TO BASICALLY SAY "THIS
IS THE FACE OF THIS MAJORITY."
THAT'S WHAT McCARTHY HAS PUT IN
MOTION.
AS I SAID, THERE ARE
CONSERVATIVES WHO SAY, FINE, YOU
KNOW, THIS IS GOING TO TURN OUT
MORE CONSERVATIVES AND WE ARE
GOING TO WIN, BUT THE FACT IS
REPUBLICANS LOST INDEPENDENTS IN
THIS MIDTERM, THE FIRST TIME
SINCE AT LEAST 1982 THAT THE
PARTY OUT OF POWER LOST
INDEPENDENT VOTERS.
ONE OF THE REASONS THEY LOST
THEM IN A MIDTERM WAS BECAUSE
ALMOST 60% OF THEM SAID THE
PARTY WAS TOO EXTREME.
IN THAT PHOTO OF GREENE AND
McCARTHY, HE IS NOW -- YOU CAN
SEE HOW HE IS ENABLING MORE
VISIBILITY FOR THE VERY KIND OF
REPUBLICANS WHO HAVE SEEDED THAT
IMPRESSION.
IT IS JUST AN ENORMOUS GAMBLE
FOR THE PARTY THAT COULD MAKE IT
TOUGHER FOR THEM TO HOLD THE
HOUSE IN 2024.
>> AND DEMOCRATS, I'M SURE,
AREN'T HAPPY THAT THEY LOST THE
HOUSE TO THE REPUBLICANS, AND
KEVIN McCARTHY IS THE NEW
SPEAKER, BUT HAVING THE
REPUBLICANS IN CHARGE AND KEVIN
McCARTHY AS SPEAKER MAY BE THE